and welcome to this video playing
anti-drone why he's playing the trumpet
you should have played t5 something else
for a change well not that I'm afraid of
the Trump just and boring can play the
same stuff all the time against the same
people okay yeah I have a bad score one
point one point five out of five against
him that's not too great okay let's do a
keep it simple approach transposing into
the caro-kann exchange which is solid
anyway and here it seems extremely
extremely dependable with this pin on
the f3 knight he has to go see three
basically queen bee three may be
interesting like a bishop f3 queen bee 7
that could be an idea queen bee 395 ok
it's not doing that we get a very yeah
somewhat simplified position now or
maybe Bishop g5 this is an option of
course nope yeah I think I can castle
here normally I don't have to cover be 7
SB 2 is hanging as well yeah preparing
p5 ok I'm insisting 1 p-5 yeah a5 is
weakening the poor a bit ok it's not a
big deal probably yeah I can't let's
have a look at that pawn
it's not going to go be4 95 maybe who I
don't know general is really not that
much going on in this position 1223 have
95 so that I can just take it it is not
really ready to play something like the
battery we shall Bob back and be sure
and Quincy to like we should be one quiz
Quincy to form a door h7 that's really
not happening I can go night I mean it
can cover age seven whenever I want and
also have an eye on a five-pound what
I'm thinking it was also if I can go be
five at the right moment yeah trying to
harass is Queen there a little bit b5 TX
now cheeks come on I want to do
something here let's do this if I take
with the light now queen a sixth is also
night to see form I'm just probably not
that great but I thought I can also take
this actually just play on that porn I
mean be form is really weakening a lot
on the CFR don't k this one for what was
you for maybe maybe so I'm preparing
something with ninety six and a four
I don't know is he doing something on
the kingside probably is but how is he
going to do that without the Queen i ah
here we go okay I'm going to push that
if he takes Knight b6 and I don't see
white keeping that pole I mean I really
have don't have much in terms of
defensive pieces so i can take here
right our context I didn't see that one
coming so I'm grabbing here Bishop takes
Queen to c4c really getting a quick
attack here maybe here sound like group
g3 and things like that don't really
believe it but this is a typical weak
spot in my player tend to not believe
things my opponent is able to do and
sometimes it really does work hmm maybe
you can just go like g3 yeah
I don't have a great discovery not be
too for what then 21 hmm d 4 would be
very principled in this pollution and
she always has Quincy one something like
that okay
unfortunately i would like to play look
beat what doesn't work and this night is
somewhat somewhat hanging night back
Quincy one I it's kind of dangerous but
Quincy one Drago King f8 here or King
that's difficult the same king of a da
King a jade yeah because of that I
really wasn't sure how dangerous is this
might be I was just thinking that this
Bishop is kind of it's some kind of
liability and maybe Bishop g6 but what
is this threatening actually i don't
know if i go f5 instead a good move f5
you cannot take on paso and I'm
threatening to move the night it
actually could be good Bishop takes a
five as an obvious idea but I don't know
if that I don't think it works
so if we trade queens are probably in
fantastic shape to time morning this is
the Queen trade I just got g4 maybe wait
it's not pre move here ok I have taking
this look at some problems now don't
have much time but i think if i take on
f2 that's going to be dangerous
returning on d to now which is a pretty
big Fork there's no threat here really
right just one check check 93 will be
deciding myself in some time decisive as
the word how difficult some difficult
stuff yeah raunchy I thought I don't
know I felt like I'm a little bit
endanger them this year this doesn't
seem to be so great engine gives Queen D
1 yeah immediately going for Queen d3s
food let us make quite a bit of sense
this is the line that the computer gives
jakes and with an advantage
engine gives this line now the tech I
mean it looks dangerous but I'm still
kind of surprised that white is supposed
to be better okay 0.7 only not that much
this is given by the engine Queen h7 m-3
queen here night age for attending this
oh yeah okay let that turn it looks
dangerous it doesn't seem to be decisive
but looks good yeah now black is better
95 and King age eight given by the comp
but this is also at least not worse okay
to leap and f5 yeah I saw some good
movie at five is also given by the comb
with a clear advantage now however the
engine wants to take and this is kind of
interesting because now it wants to play
rook a form and I think I would have
taken why isn't this good okay it seems
to be okay chaplet not all that decisive
okay what get spawn see Aurora he's
probably threatening this anti five
hangs this is given by the computer was
just a slight edge from black okay it's
difficult to say now i'm more more or
less and winning the gamer thinking yeah
22 or strong and that wins wins as well
yeah yeah that was an ok game I believe
interesting interesting fight ok well
thanks for watching